It's your resident beauty nerd here:
Michelle of Lab Muffin Science and
today we're talking about anecdotal
evidence. It sounds sort of abstract but
it's really important to understand
because that sort of explains why my
channel exists; why science is important
when it comes to figuring out what
actually works for beauty products and
for other things in life as well like
medical treatments and nutrition and
supplements. If you like videos about the
science behind beauty products, make sure
you click the thumbs up, subscribe to my
channel, and click the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos.
Anecdotal evidence is when someone says that something worked for them or someone
they know. Basically it's a one-off
example of something working or not
working, for example, I use this cream the
next day a pimple disappeared and so
this cream must work for treating
pimples. Or... I took some multivitamins
then my cold got better, so that means
multivitamins fix my cold. Or my
grandma smoked continuously and died
at 92
so cigarettes aren't that bad for your
health. We see anecdotal evidence
everywhere in beauty: testimonials and
reviews are all forms of anecdotal
evidence and anecdotal evidence isn't
just limited to regular consumers- expert
opinions experience and case reports are
often forms of anecdotal evidence as
well. Medical professionals, scientists,
and beauty professionals all use and
misuse anecdotal evidence. It's simply
part of being human. All human beings
have evolved to naturally be subjective
and prone to biases, distortions in our
thinking that stopped us from being
purely objective and rational machines.
These biases actually helped us survive
through the ages but unfortunately they
don't help us as much in the modern
world.
Anecdotal evidence can be very useful in
some situations. If you're going for a
beauty treatment you probably want an
experienced therapist rather than a
brand-new one, but the problem with
anecdotal evidence is while it sometimes
really useful it isn't reliable, and we
as humans have a bias to give it far
more weight than it deserves. Anecdotes
aren't good enough evidence for saying a
particular treatment led to a particular
outcome
and if anecdotal evidence disagrees with
good scientific studies and there's no
plausible explanation for how a
particular treatment might work, we
should go with what the science says.
Anecdotal evidence can be incredibly
convincing, it's a lot easier to believe
someone's heartfelt story than it is to
try to understand faceless, complicated,
and often scarily technical scientific
data, even if there are many someones
behind that data. This is part of the
reason why documentaries are so
compelling and why a lot of people who
are pushing pseudoscience choose to use
documentaries to present their case.
And our love of personal stories was great
for human survival: if you avoided all
red berries because one person died from
eating them you end up living a lot
longer and passing on your genes, even if
not all red berries are dangerous.
This quick mental shortcut allowed us to stayalive most of the time, but unfortunately
these quick mental shortcuts, these
cognitive biases that inform our gut
feelings, they also give us a distorted
view of reality. We live in a much more
complex world now and we need and have
much better tools to work out what's
going on then anecdotal evidence. I know
it can feel really unnatural to ignore
your gut feelings but a lot of the time
these gut feelings and instincts evolved
to help us survive under very [different]
circumstances than our modern world.
Being aware of these sorts of biases
that we have towards anecdotal evidence
means we can compensate for it. This
makes us more aware of what actually
works and makes us much less vulnerable
to being manipulated by dodgy marketing.
Being aware of these irrationalities
that we all naturally have means we can
make better decisions about what to do
and what to buy. So let's go through some
of the problems with anecdotal evidence.
I'll be focusing on the ones that are
more relevant to beauty products. Some of
these issues have fancy technical
names, so I'll put the names of them on
the screen as I'm explaining them. One of
the biggest problems with anecdotal
evidence is that things get better on
their own a lot of the time. Back to the
pimple example, as most of us have
probably experienced, pimples tend to get
better on their own in about a week, and
if you're anything like me, you probably
won't bother doing anything about it
until about three days in when it's at
its ripest. So there I am putting cream
on a single pimple, and it clears up
about three days later. To me, it looks
like it works, but maybe in a different
timeline I use the light pen instead,
and the pimple cleared up, so it looks
like the light pen worked. Or in a third
timeline I used a pimple patch and that
looked like it worked, but all along, if I
just left it alone it would have cleared
up as well, and so really none of them
worked. Or maybe say I use the pimple
cream and my pimple went away faster
than normal and so it looked like it
worked, but that week I also used a new
cleanser, and applied some exfoliant, and
went on a health kick, and ate a whole
bunch of vegetables. Any of these could
have helped the pimple go away faster
but I only linked the pimple cream to
the pimple in my mind because that's
what I expected to work. Even worse, a lot
of the time we forget about
longer-lasting treatments and we only
remember the last thing we used. I might
have even started on the contraceptive
pill which takes a while to start
working to reduce pimples, then I use the
pimple cream and then the hormones
kicked in and made the pimple go away
faster than normal, but I think it's just
the cream. These are all examples of how
one thing happening doesn't mean that it
caused the next thing. Just because I
used the pimple cream and the pimple
went away, doesn't mean that the pimple
cream worked. Another issue is that
humans just aren't great at observing
things. I'm sure you've all had the
experience where you and a friend can't
agree on something really mundane, like
what color shirt someone was wearing at
a party, or whether McDonald's
cheeseburgers are actually getting
smaller. One researcher actually
developed a method that could make 1/3
of people believe that a made-up event
happened in their childhood, and not only
did they believe it they would even tack
on extra details when they talked about
this event to someone else! We're really
good at filling gaps in our memory with
random stuff and tricking ourselves into
believing things. With a pimple unless
you've been really carefully measuring
it every day you can easily trick
yourself into thinking it's getting
bigger or smaller or it's going lighter or redder. If you
spent a lot of money on the pimple cream
and you really want it to work, you might
even subconsciously trick yourself into
believing that you can see a change,
forgetting all the times that you used
it and it didn't work. This is an example
of confirmation bias or wishful thinking,
and this effect can be bigger for more
expensive products, it's called post
purchase rationalization: where you don't
want to believe that you've wasted your
money on something that didn't work.
As I've talked about in my e-book "The Lab
Muffin Guide to Basic Skincare" there are
a few ways that you can try to make your
observations as objective as possible, so
things like photos and skin diaries. But
while these can help you trick yourself
less, it still isn't foolproof. So ideally
how could we tell if a pimple cream
really helps clear up pimples? What we
have to do is set up a fair test, so we
can specifically compare the pimple
cream with no cream at all. We'd make
sure that everything else stayed the
same. For example, if you had two
identical pimples on either side of your
face, then everything you ate should
affect both pimples equally. You could
also make sure that you used every other
skincare product equally on both sides
of your face or stopped every other
product altogether. This is called
"controlling the variables". If the pimple
cream worked, we'd also want to make sure it wasn't a one-off fluke, where the
lighting made the pimple look smaller,
or the pimple was a less severe pimple
than normal all the person scratched one
pimple in their sleep, but not the other.
Instead of just trying the pimple cream
on one pimple, we could try the pimple
cream on lots and lots of pimples and
then get rid of the one-off fluke
results. If we wanted to test whether a
specific ingredient worked for pimples,
we could even make two creams: one with
the ingredient, and one without, and test
the two creams against each other to
make sure the people recording the
results aren't biased. We could label the
creams "A" and "B" and not tell them which
one was which. And that's pretty much
what science does. It sets up fair tests
that get rid of as much human
subjectivity and bias as possible. So hopefully that gives you a better idea of
why scientific evidence is better than anecdotal evidence. If science says one thing, but anecdotes say
another you should go with what the
science says. But one of the big issues
with skincare is that there's just not
that many high-quality scientific
studies around. The best ones are for
prescription products or for more
serious skin conditions like rosacea. A
lot of studies aren't fair tests, or they
test only one specific product that's
too different from a product you're
using to draw any convincing comparisons.
Or maybe they just didn't test enough
people to say much one way or another. So
if we don't have a lot of science to
guide us, that's where personal
experience and reviews become much more
valuable because it's the best we have.
But given how subjective and prone to
biases this anecdotal evidence is, there
are a few things we should keep in mind
so that we aren't misled. Reviews can be
a fantastic resource for finding
products that work well for you, but make
sure you don't believe every review you
read. As well as all of the problems with
anecdotal evidence that I mentioned
before, there are a few extra things to
keep in mind with reviews. Many companies
post fake reviews of their products. They
might pay someone to churn out tons of
positive reviews and post them online
under fake profiles. Even if they aren't
fake, reviews can also be incentivized. If
a company gives out free samples, or pays
someone to review their products, this
conflict of interest can mean that the
review is more favorable than it might
otherwise be. But at the same time just
because someone was paid or it is a free
product, it doesn't mean that that's the
only reason why a review is positive. And
even if someone is reviewing a product
that they bought themselves, it doesn't
mean that it will be completely
objective. There are issues I mentioned
before like confirmation bias, where
someone sees a change because they're
expecting a change, and post-purchase
rationalization, especially if it's an
expensive product. There are also issues
if you're looking at multiple reviews.
you might see a lot of very good reviews
or very bad reviews, and that's because
humans are kind of lazy.
Unless something works really well or
really badly, we're not likely to go to
the trouble of writing a review. We can't
get a
good idea of how likely it is we'll get
a good result, how representative these
reviews are. If we see ten rave reviews
we can't easily tell if it's a niche
product where only ten people tried it
and they all loved it, or a mediocre but
popular product where thousands of
people tried it, but it only worked well
for ten people. Very few people update
their reviews, so we don't know if the
product continued to work well for
someone, or if they change their mind
after trying it for longer. Humans are
also better and remembering recent
things more clearly. Products with
immediate results will probably get more
positive reviews than a product that
works better, but takes a longer time to
start working. If you've ever read
skincare reviews you'll know that
different people can have very different
experiences with the same product. In
scientific studies the people they tried
a product on are usually described very
specifically. You can work out how close
you are to the source of people they
tried the product on. But in reviews you
usually know very little about the
reviewer. So where does this leave us as
beauty consumers? This is where I talk
about what I personally think is a
sensible approach. You might disagree and
that is perfectly valid your best bet
for products that will work for you, are
those that have enough scientific
evidence to back up its effectiveness,
but also have a large number of
reasonably objective positive reviews
from people in a similar situation as
you. If there isn't any scientific
evidence for that exact product, then you
want there to be some evidence for its
active ingredients. If you don't have
that then you want a plausible mechanism
a scientifically sound explanation for
why it could possibly work and no
compelling scientific reason that it
wouldn't work. If anecdotal evidence
disagrees with the scientific evidence
then you should go with what the
scientific evidence says. The higher the
risk, both health-wise and in terms of
budget- the stronger that scientific
evidence should be. Anecdotal evidence is
still useful in helping us decide which
products to try, as long as we keep in
mind the limitations and don't treat it
as proof of something working. I hope you
enjoyed this video it's a little bit
different it's more about why we care
about science rather than the science
behind a particular product, so please
let me know what you think in the
comments. If you like videos on the
science behind beauty products, click
the thumbs up and you can subscribe to
my channel. You can also find me on my
blog labmuffin.com and on Instagram
under Lab Muffin Beauty Science.